are we gonna get more into the origin  story of loop we got a little bit of  information in Jessica Jones but I  really want to get that back story no I  think it did a great job I mean I I'm  excited about a certain episode that  really delves into that that order story  and i'm happy it was a very difficult  shoot but uh you'll see why um it's a  great story and i think the fans will be  happy with it i think we paid homage to  some of the stuff the past and that the  fanboys would really get a kick out of  it I'm excited about it but it's  seamless it's effortless and I think  it's a great episodes on the board at  that specific one could be the apostasy  someone named jessica jones pop-up  Analysis Unit listen I don't know she  could get it yeah yeah